good morning can i help you
yes i'm from techstar about a new phone
system for you i was wondering if i
could talk to michael scott
i'm sorry he's not in right now
really
he's never around when i come by shoot
they have new phone systems now that can
ring directly to a salesman or someone
presses star and they go to accounting
basically 95 of my job
but i'd like to see a machine that puts
out candy for everyone
vending machine
how about i make an appointment to come
back that way i know he'll be here
that is a great idea
great
um
oh boy
see
sprilly
michael scott manager hi how are you oh
hi
yeah hey look at that
i can assure you we don't need a new
system though happy with ours
hey
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
um
[Music]
[Applause]
what was that that was funny that was
funny
let's go do it to somebody else
hey
nice
what's wrong michael it's like a gum in
my hair
you do this
just
stinks don't touch it please don't touch
it you got a ton of dandruff okay let me
be how'd you get going i was walking in
and i noticed something shiny under
stanley's car and i got under to see
what it was and i messed up my hair all
for a stupid piece of tin foil but best
case scenario you thought it was a
quarter kill me
right now we have peanut butter in the
kitchen
i don't feel like peanut butter give me
an ice cream sandwich nope not for you
it's for your hair and it is 9 a.m
no dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good
tastes good too oh don that's disgusting
wow a lot of calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please
oh yeah that's nice
you gonna answer that kel
all right thanks
dunder mifflin this is kevin
please hold while i transfer you
oscar your mom
charles is having kevin cover the phones
for a while
how do i say this diplomatically
i think kevin is doing exactly as well
as anyone might have expected someone
like him to perform in a position like
that
please hold andy phone call nope stay
there
kev i thought we nailed the whole
transfer thing earlier yeah i wrote it
on my hand but then i washed it it is
transfer extension and then transfer
again okay andy get ready transfer here
we go extension
transfer
oh man
it is one three four kev kevin come on
you are murdering the nardole this is
kevin please hold and i will transfer
you
you're bad at this too don't answer that
call just transfer the damn goal your
call is very important to us please
[Applause]
my maid died
[Music]
oh
it hurts
i know
it hurts my heart
nerves my stomach
hurts my arms
okay well
why are you laying like that
thanks
how did you push away the bad thoughts
like what
like maybe
the real reason they left
was because
there were things
they wanted you to do
in bed
that were
what
foreign and scary i
i don't know that you didn't want to try
this
some wine might have helped
do you know what i'm referring to
excuse me how long is the wait for a
table for two
i would never ever serve you not in a
million billion years
it's a nice tux i know it belonged to my
grandfather
he was buried in it so
family
heirloom so what's the deal we got to
pay for our own drinks that's life come
on it'll be fun and besides i'm a
roulette expert impossible roulette is
not a game of skill it is a game of
chance
i could always kind of win over that oh
really
yeah how would you do that
mind control
you can't be serious
are you serious ever since i was a
little kid
like eight or nine i could
sort of control things with my mind
i don't believe you continue
it was just little things you know like
i could make something shake or i could
make a marble fall off the counter you
know just little things
that's ridiculous you know what
uh
why don't you move that coatrack
excuse me everyone attention in the
office please jim is about to prove his
telekinetic powers and he needs absolute
silence
go ahead
okay i'll try
oh my god
what
oh nothing
pam's on vacation and she gets back
tomorrow so it'll be nice to see her
it'll be nice and uh she set a date for
the wedding with roy
uh june summer so that'll be nice
and that's that
what
oh nothing
jim's been looking at me kind of a lot
all week
i would be creeped out by it but it's
nothing compared to the way michael
looks at me
you